to coronavirus news now that masks are
once again required for clark county
employees the spotlight is on local
businesses to submit
their plan to combat covid the deadline
for those mitigation plans is just
hours away many spots are gearing up for
the changes now
madison kimbrough stopped by two local
restaurants earlier tonight
and that motion carries the clark county
board of commissioners voted tuesday
requiring all
employees to wear face masks while in
public indoor spaces
they also announced that businesses must
submit a covet plan to further detail
how they are following safety protocols
our guideline
is that all employees have to wear masks
and that's what we have done already
over at saffron flavors of india owner
rasheesh patel has been keeping up with
safety guidelines
and has no issue with having his
employees wear face coverings
in addition the county announced that
businesses must also post signage
encouraging customers to get vaccinated
that however patel does have an issue
with
and says it puts him and his business in
a tough spot
i feel like they're asking me to take a
side saying that
i think you should get vaccinated we get
customers
from both spectrums we don't want to
alienate one or the other
that's where i have the big problem
because i'm not i'm not
i'm not a medical person i don't want to
take a side
a couple stores down at cups and bowls
owner stephen hung
says he and his employees have been very
cautious and still implement distancing
as much as possible
we installed a plexiglass just a way to
protect my employee and also protect all
our guts that
coming in here usually about like six
customers
in our restaurant and usually we just
lock the door or like
they can put the order in and they came
outside away
restaurants along with grocery stores
indoor malls and other indoor venues
that host gatherings of more than 250
people
are required to submit a covet plan no
later than monday at 8 a.m